ごちゃ二税今やユーチューバーというものも誰しもが知っている言葉になってきました
人気有名ユーチューバーもいれば本土ユーチューバーとかわかんないけど何だか動画
出せるだけみたいな人もいるんですけどもやっぱり
登録37百度に言いますよろしくお願い致しますまあそんななんか自分がすごいていた
わけなんですけども一応間にも数字があるんでキュアのこれから youtube やり
たいとかユーチューバーだけどあんまり良い動画が何か見られない何でだろうってドア
の作り方で困っているひとつにこの youtube 大先生が動画の作り方を
レクチャーしてあげようと思います宜しくお願いしますだけでチャンネルと
読者数日本一が教えるユーチューバー講座やっていきましょうというわけで本日の
ゲストはこちらの底辺ユーチューバーですどうぞ
ども
宜しくお願宜しくお願いしますああ
そんな前はよろしくお願いします建物ステーションですよろしくお願いしますたくねー
じゃねーかじめさんが受けて麻生削ってな
6面ステーションってユーチューバーいるんですけども顔がめちゃ似てて慎重たから
なんで縦に伸ばして縦目ステーションということで僕が勝手につけさせて頂きました
ない敵
立明さん実はユーチューバーということでそうですね実はいつ頃からやり始めに慣れて
いる
多分2年前ぐらいですねもう2年前結構じゃあやってますねまぁもうちょち動画は何本
ぐらい出されました
全部の今までブームに160とか
めっちゃらずにゃんはたしてやマーケッ結構出してるネタ振っては気になるチャンネル
登録者数は
ば1400どうですかね今
あのもよく線いったねーそうですね誰のおかげでしょうか始めたのおかげで廃絶は
ちょい同園でてるんですけども彼もまたユーチューバーの一人というわけで
われ
動画見たことねーんださっきかるーくみたところを改善点がまだまだあったんで彼が
くそだが参考にどうすればもっと見られるようになるのか
動画の作り方をレクチャーしていこうと思います
佐知代
かっ一羽ペンステーションはじめ施設を打って出るんですね出るんですねほんとれて
最新の動画見ているかはいそうそうですね
まあこのさまでなんだ軽快で高そのアップしちゃうとアレが手順がなくてそれねでが
住んで的なソースねない
上京して今高いまあ今の3棟はないボンズもナイス
なんていう動画これフリー船尾足でキャッチできるまで終われません
なるほどこれは面白いと思ってやられているん
そうですねこれいける場合フィルター完成はいいと思いますよ
これのキス嫌いじゃないんですただエバフリー3 b 4足でキャッツできるまではれ
ませんっていうのがであれば
サムネイルに振りすぎとかうーんもっとこうま兼久要素がないと
つ見てみましょうえっ
失礼致しますはい
何ですか古代竜なんだって自分で作り深さともが見ていますよね
ああ
見ていきましょう
あまたで配布するのに白衣がですねひょっとして
ウィンズ乾門の弾み雪の白衣装思いねこれ背景にものを言ってもいいことでいいかも
なぁ遊び者となる持ってんだみたいなので惜しい兄感湧いて来ずに見てくれてる
ユーザー触れ可能性があるんねもうものを置いておく流れといいとらー利益作戦でき
ます
はい
日ジムでが全員でひねるしか聞こえんで設定できんかったけちゃんですができるんです
けど家まで聞いた時これぐらいでまあまあ今日行ったんですよ
まぁちょっとほどいうかなんてならざるん
ん
またてるですねやってること言ってることが違うってよくあることですかだろう
やっぱで頭が終わるので
今終わりかけなんだこれ終わりかけちょっと音が何買って音なかったと言いますね
hey hey
が見ていいですかねぇ
難なくあああん
これなんか動画につなぎみたいなあーなくニュートンとかなんだなぁ
強欲しいライブ気味で読みたいそうそうを作ろうという時にこっち
自分なりに作ってみたんですけどへっくしゅ
水が見ていきましょうね
以下目ですね
尺ですよ
カットそこできてねー
うっ難しいすれば位悪い
見てみまーはい行きました4日
スポッチャやってくれたんだ
なんですかキャッチできた旬が映ってなかったはい
チャッん
これは関与できた瞬間は映さないか
の人でぼくわるいねあのーん
良くするため
山版違う動画でお会いしましょう
ばいばい
まだ入っ
たかぽんとかで上がる前でなんだ前から奴の家をしなさい
一番人気の動画見てみた作家そうですね髪セット道はたしてんの6000回3組を見
てるでしょ
分かったね
輪っかうんする恐れ
定評黒ねっ
グラッね誘導す出せ映像した彼はこれちょっと叩かれているんでは5尾セットすぎて草
まあしたりちょっと誰か出てる奴だったんだからでもねせず取れればいいんだけどそう
ですね中審査でもできる
方はた済みだしな
奪っちゃう君が言ってることをにはいろんな格好いいよ
ますけど住まいうん
今のぽいな
出てないなふわふわ感出てないよいつでてでそうなテキストが透けないねぇ
まあなんかあることがいいと思うんだけどちょっとお休みかもねー
何だした動画飲んでどこだしたこれ館での
たでしたん
ご視聴ありがとうございますまた
チャンネル登録よろしく
ていました祭
少々聴取書
[音楽]
収集朱儁エンディングのこと分
さっきの吉凶星期の動画が強いこいてるだろ鳥肌が立ちました
じゃあお爪やつみたロス8ですよねスマホに動画て真珠しているそうですずっとスマホ
なんですよ
見て欲しかったらパソコンで者た日でしたほうがいいかもしれねえですねまぁ物による
けど
とか言っ神鳥は石ですねはめない子だってんなお前のギャッツビーの max 食べて
みた
はい
もう待ってからもある曲がまいり入っ
これすき席これすき船や緑がいいんですかね皆さん
あ至らず
内の遊歩道がは
まずか
うわーうわーうわーやばプラバン
んだろうね待ってどんだけーでくれたんだぜ
フってやつは
うーんばかあさーんお前出ればいいと思うけど危ないからマネしないでねとか
そーせいがあったは異常でしたねうんもしあなたが有名ユーチューバーだったら是非
あって案内イカロス市民がバロスあれっ
[音楽]
レモールの熊さーん
おい
最新の動画で運動つっていうのはパパの神ゲーも悪いねいってらっしゃいとんでもない
嘘つけねー
がんばれ
me
ええええええ
あっはぁ